[Musique]
cette invité ce matin c'est vous
Valentin Gendreau bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation cette
journaliste cette l'auteur plusieurs
enquêtes lors desquelles vous êtes
infiltrés vous avez enquêté sans
préciser vous étiez journaliste vous
avez signé les enchaînés un an avec les
travailleurs précaires et sous-payés en
2020 une autre enquête va beaucoup faire
parler ça s'appelait flic un journaliste
un filtré la police vous ai raconté
votre expérience en tant que policier
dans un quartier populaire de Paris
après l'école de police le quotidien
d'un commissariat ordinaire avec des
jeunes à peine formés ça avait fait
beaucoup réagir au sein de la police
nationale et vous revenez donc avec un
nouveau livre toujours dans le même
esprit ça s'appelle lit 3P un filtrée
aux éditions Albin Michel lit 3P pour
bien comprendre c'est l'infirmerie
psychiatrique de la préfecture de police
de Paris et en réalité ça c'est votre
première infiltration sortie de l'école
de police avant d'aller ensuite dans ce
commissariat du 19e pourquoi cette
publication d'abord dans le désordre
rapidement
vous avez raison c'est dans le désordre
quand je me lance dans l'infiltration
dans la police mon objectif c'est de
pouvoir raconter le quotidien et les
conditions de travail des policiers donc
quand je j'obtiens mon affectation dans
le commissaire du 19e arrondissement de
Paris je pars tout de suite avec l'idée
de leur raconter ça parce que c'est
c'est le pourquoi je me suis engagé
pendant deux ans dans cette dans cette
infiltration là une fois que j'ai écrit
et publié et
effectuer la promotion de flics j'ai ce
sujet psychiatrie qui est comme vous
l'avez rappelé ma première affectation
dans la dans la police c'est pas un
sujet que j'ai choisi c'est une
infiltration par hasard mais il y a un
vrai sujet là-dedans parce que on parle
de la psychiatrie d'urgence de personnes
qui sont interpellées par des policiers
qui ensuite dans un cas sur deux environ
sont hospitalisés sans consentement
c'est à dire qu'on leur demande pas leur
avis donc c'est de la psychiatrie à haut
niveau
ou la dangerosité des personnes pour
elle-même pour les autres et tout de
suite au centre du jeu
et ensuite vous avez les histoires de
ces personnes là et c'est ça qui m'a
intéressé c'était de pouvoir raconter de
mettre des visages sur sur ces personnes
de raconter pourquoi elles avaient été
hospitalisées comment est-ce qu'elles
tombent dans la maladie mentale et aussi
et surtout
l'enjeu l'impact que ça implique pour
les familles qui sont directement
concernées par ces questions là
puisqu'elle le vivent au quotidien vous
racontez d'abord votre expérience dans
cette institut et ensuite vous allez
retrouver des gens que vous aviez vu
là-bas leur famille également pour
connaître leur parcours au début c'est
un peu au Vol au-dessus d'un nid de
coucou vous êtes affecté pendant 15 mois
donc à la conduite des patients en gros
ambulanciers c'est ça à l'e3p cette
infirmerie psychiatrique de la
préfecture de police de Paris d'abord
c'est quoi les trois P vous parlez d'une
gare de triage de la folie parisienne
je vous donne un exemple très simple
vous avez un homme qui va tenter de
voler une voiture avec une petite
cuillère par exemple ça c'est déjà
arrivé j'ai déjà vu j'ai un ventes rien
les policiers vont l'interpeller et
pendant la garde à vue vont estimer que
cette personne présente des troubles du
comportement et ils vont l'orienter vers
les trois P l'infirmerie psychiatrique
et à l'infirmière psychiatrique comme
psychiatre va déterminer si cette
personne nécessite une hospitalisation
sans consentement ou pas et le cas de
Paris pardon c'est un peu particulier
parce que en province c'est pas les 3P
on envoie les gens en hôpital
psychiatrique ici il y a cette espèce de
SAS qui n'existe pas ailleurs c'est une
structure qui est unique en Europe
effectivement vous avez raison les trois
P c'est c'est une vieille un vieil
héritage de la naissance de la
préfecture de police de Paris au début
du 19e et puis ensuite vous avez cette
création là au 19e au niveau au moment
de la commune donc 1870 1871 l'idée
c'était de pouvoir séparer les gens qui
sont en garde à vue mais qui ont commis
par exemple des vols des gens qui
présentent des
dans quelles conditions c'est à dire que
vous avez un psychiatre qui
estime si oui ou non on doit l'emmener
vers l'infirmerie psychiatrique et après
à l'infirmerie psychiatrique il y a
encore un autre psychiatre c'est très
encadré cette histoire là et la
détention en elle-même ça se passe
comment vous avez 10 chambres
d'isolement donc c'est à dire qu'on peut
on ne peut pas les ouvrir de l'Intérieur
quelqu'un qui est admis à l'I3P doit
taper la porte par exemple si elle veut
aller aux toilettes si elle a un besoin
de s'élever un verre d'eau par exemple
etc on peut pas s'échapper de cette
structure là donc il y a quand même un
côté carcéral et dans la grande majorité
des cas les gens sont attachés c'est à
dire qu'on leur met une sangle qui
retient les bras ou les avant-bras au
buste et évidemment vous avez aussi des
neuroleptiques qui sont prescrits donc
en fait les gens l'idée si vous voulez
c'est de gérer le temps de l'urgence et
de casser les crises parce que dans la
dans l'immense majorité des personnes
admises dans cette structure là ces gens
sont en crise et c'est une détention qui
dure 48 heures maximum et dans les faits
ça reste une vingtaine d'heures environ
et de qui dépend les trois P parce que
ça dépend de la Préfecture de police de
Paris c'est dans le nom mais c'est un
peu plus complexe que ça parce qu'une
partie des personnes là-bas qui sont
salariés par la Mairie de Paris oui
c'est une espèce de flou vous parlez
d'État dans l'état c'est un état dans
l'état c'est à dire que c'est très
opaque c'est très encadré par la loi
mais ça reste quand même très opaque en
terme de pratique à l'intérieur même de
la structure ça appartient à la
préfecture de police de Paris il y a eu
des rapports pour demander la
suppression de cette structure là et
pour la la remettre dans le le droit
commun ou le droit médical commun c'est
à dire un service d'urgence
psychiatrique comme ça se passe partout
ailleurs en France la préfecture de
police ne fait la sourde oreille ça
appartient aux bijou de famille de la
préfecture de police donc il est hors de
question pour l'instant que qu'on le
supprime mais les infirmiers les
surveillants les cadres de santé sont
payés par la Mairie de Paris donc
effectivement c'est vraiment statut très
à cheval entre deux entre deux
structures et puis les policiers comme
vous on va vous étiez adjoint de
sécurité à ce moment-là qui sont
affectés notamment donc au transfert des
patients et vous racontez comme dans le
livre flic à pas de formation non il y a
même il y a pas de formation pour pour
gérer des personnes qui pourraient
présenter une crise pendant un transfert
par exemple on est envoyé sur le terrain
tout de suite et en fait on est envoyé
parce que souvent ce sont des hommes
d'ailleurs qui occupent ces postes là et
qui sont un peu plus vieux que les
policiers contractuels classiques
c'est-à-dire que un policier contractuel
généralement il a 20 22 ans moi quand je
suis arrivé dans ce poste à ce poste là
j'avais 29 ans donc j'étais un peu plus
vieux que les autres
et il vous racontez votre infiltration
vous allez plus loin dans le livre parce
que pour votre enquête vous retrouvez
plusieurs années plus tard des patients
auxquels vous avez eu à faire que vous
avez croisé leurs proches leurs familles
vous décrivez leur parcours des
contextes difficiles une folie qui
s'installe dans le quotidien souvent à
partir de l'adolescence et des choses
qui dégénèrent des tentatives pour s'en
sortir pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
voulu retrouver ses patients après votre
expérience votre infiltration
mon avis personnel sur la psychiatrie
c'est qu'on en parle lorsque le sang
coule on a eu l'exemple assez récent
avec l'affaire Lola ou d'ailleurs d'un
point de vue pénal il est pas question
psychiatrie mais on a quand même parlé
de psychiatrie dans cette affaire là
mais
j'ai aussi rencontré un infirmier qui
s'appelle Rodolphe et c'est infirmé là
mais explique que on parle de
psychiatrie lorsque le sang coule ça
concerne peut-être 1 à 2% des cas mais
les 98 à 99% restants il s'agit
d'angoisse il s'agit de peur il s'agit
de crise et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de mettre des mots et de
montrer factuellement l'angoisse et la
peur que le sang qui coule donc on a un
peu une solution de facilité qui
consiste à parler de
quand même assez affreux commis par des
personnes qui souffrent de de maladies
mentales mais l'immense majorité des cas
c'est des crises et d'angoisse ce qui
m'intéressait c'était moi d'aller
au-delà du fait divers du fait divers
barbare et de pouvoir raconter comment
on tombe dans la maladie mentale et de
raconter par exemple dans le livre il y
a un personnage qui s'appelle Thomas
évidemment c'est un pseudonyme qui a été
hospitalisé pendant quatre ans en
hôpital psychiatrique j'ai rencontré ses
parents
son frère sa sœur les parents
m'expliquent que pendant six ans ils ont
eu toutes les peines du monde à pouvoir
le faire hospitaliser donc ils vivaient
chez eux leurs parents de violence
exactement ils vivaient avec un marteau
sous leur matelas parce qu'ils avaient
peur de leur enfant il savait plus quoi
faire et ce n'est qu'un jour où il a mis
un coup de skateboard dans la porte de
son voisin que là les policiers sont
intervenus et que les parents ont pu le
faire hospitaliser ça ça raconte tout ça
c'est ces témoignages là ça montre que
Thomas c'est pas quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement dangereux il a pas de certes
il est hospitalisé quand il met un
skateboard mais c'est pas quelque chose
de dramatique il s'en est pas pris à
quelqu'un si vous voulez mais
ça montre que il y a toute la difficulté
pour les parents à faire hospitaliser
leurs enfants ça montre le quotidien
complètement brisé cette vie et cette
famille qui est quand même assez
dévastée par la maladie mentale de leur
enfant et ça il y a le côté loterie
aussi pourquoi est-ce que ça leur arrive
à eux pourquoi pas à vous pourquoi pas
moi c'est toute la loterie de la maladie
mentale merci beaucoup Valentin Jean
gros on est déjà pressé par le temps
c'est la fin de cette interview mais je
rappelle le nom de ce livre qui
s'appelle lit 3P infiltrée aux éditions
Albin Michel c'est aussi passionnant que
que flic lecture que je vous conseille
et qui est sorti tout récemment merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin